الجيل المقبل من روبوتات المحادثه وجه
ودود يستمع الى سؤال ثم يقدم اجابه منطقيه
بشكل طبيعي
انه الانسان الرقمي الذي يحاكي المحادثات
البشريه لم يعد مجرد تطبيق ذكاء صناعي
يتيح للاشخاص كتابه الاسئله وتلقي الاجوبه
على مختلف الموضوعات بل انه واجهه جديده
يمكنها استخدام نصوص تولد بواسطه الذكاء
الاصطناعي للتحدث مع المستخدمين يتم كل
هذا من خلال محادثه طبيعيه وسلسه مع صوره
رمزيه رقميه لروبوت الدردشه تشبه الى حد
كبير الانسان الحقيقي
من روبوتات المحادثه الاكثر محدوديه في
الماضي
[موسيقى]
تعرفه الحاسوب اذا اعطيتها كلمه او عده
كلمات كيف تكمل الجمله باكثر طرق عقلانيه
في برامج الدردشه التقليديه كان لدينا فقط
اسئله واجوبه اي ان روبوت الدردشه يعرف ما
اذا كنت تسال سؤالا معينا فيعطيك اجابه
محدده هنا يولد الروبوت اجابات جديده بحسب
الاسئله التي تطرحها
يقول القائمون على هذه التكنولوجيا ان
الناس سيكونون اكثر انخراطا في محادثه
شبيهه بالانسان لكن دون اهامهم بالاعتقاد
انهم يتحدثون الى شخص حقيقي يعد انشاء
تجربه اكثر واقعيه في مقدمه اهتمامات
شركات الذكاء الاصطناعي كهذه الشركه
الفرنسيه هنا يمكن للروبوت الدردشه
الاتصال بالعملاء ويمكن للمستخدمين التحدث
اليه لنقرا فوق المربعات عبر الانترنت
فحسب اما السبب وراء ذلك
الصوت مهم جدا لان التفاعل بطبيعه من خلال
المحادثه اسهل واسرع من الكتابه ب 60 مره
شهدت تكنولوجيا روبوتات دردشه الذكاء
الاصطناعي قفزات هائله في السنوات الاخيره
فاضحت تعتمد على التفاعل الصوتي رغم
صعوبته بدل الاعتماد على النصوص فقط وبعد
ان اضحت روبوتات المحادثه تحاكي الواقع
اكثر فاكثر كم سنمضي من الوقت قبل ان
نتمكن من تمييز البشر من الالات